dieser krieg ist extrem unberechenbar
[Musik]
die russische armee
die schlägt zu in orten in
nachbarschaften wo kein militär in der
nähe ist das ganze macht angst also
diese diese ganze stimmung die ständigen
sirenen die ein luftalarm ankündigen
dann hört man oft
wohingegen die beschossen werden dann
hört selber die explosionen man hört
auch natürlich die abwehr von der
ukrainischen armee das anders zu sehen
die geräusche die bilder ja es ist
beängstigend für für alle menschen und
ich sehe das jetzt auch hier hier in
levi war natürlich sehr viele menschen
hin geflohen sind die aus anderen
regionen kamen wie zum beispiel tief wie
zb nikolai sch das kann schon sehr
bedeutend sein
die stimme menschen ist ganz klar wir
gewinnen wir
lassen uns nicht unterkriegen von der
russischen armee von russland von herr
putin wir kämpfen egal wie lange egal
was es kosten wird also die menschen
sind wirklich alle dabei ich glaube auch
das den nationalstolz sehr gewachsen ist
auch natürlich der bezug zum präsidenten
zur residenz geht er von allen geschätzt
wird und die menschen jetzt sagen er ist
ein guter präsident im krieg weil weil
er sich für uns einsetzt weil er ja mit
uns kämpft und ich glaube diese diese
verbundenheit von den menschen dieses
dieses zusammensein und diese einigkeit
der menschen ist etwas was in den
letzten wochen definitiv gewachsen ist
ich glaube es euch ganz selten gesehen
vielleicht eigentlich noch noch
nirgendwo anders
[Musik]
was interessant ist was ich jetzt auch
hier in wien gesehen hat ist dass sich
menschen tatsächlich eine neue realität
aufbauen der alltag muss weitergehen
auch im krieg was man zb den beef sieht
ist dass viele geschäfte wieder offen
sind dass viele restaurants wieder offen
sind dass selbst der bürgermeister
gesagt hat wir müssen weitermachen wir
lebens vor einem krieg aber wir können
russland auch nicht unsere wirtschaft
zerstören lassen und diese dieses stück
alltag dieses stück normalität zu
integrieren das glaube ich auch ganz
ganz wichtig für die menschen besonders
deshalb weil natürlich fast zehn
millionen menschen ihr haus ihr haus ihr
zuhause verlassen haben viele sind ins
ausland gegangen sehr viele sind auch in
der ukraine selbst umgezogen an
sicherere orte gezogen und ja man sieht
man sieht immer wieder menschen die ja
die natürlich ein schweres schicksal
erlitten haben und die gleichzeitig
werde ich aufgeben wie aufstehen und
weitermachen
[Musik]